[Laughter]
um
[Laughter]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman he
is a beta male 1
[Music]
david pacman
he is
david pacman
he is
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman
they're emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse will we we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman obeying
a male dog but another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman
he is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
david pacman he is a baby
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming out i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you we're not communicating
you're actually like
and you're wasting my time i appreciate
that
all right
goodbye goodbye
[Applause]
that's a progressive vote
all men who are progressive are males
who are progressive are weak people
they are weak people and why have these
people on it doesn't even
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
dumps
big
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
donald trump insisted multiple times
that it was
massive dumps that led him to lose the
election which is just
dumps dumps
dumps
[Music]
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to once
dumps dumps dumps
dumps dump big massive dumpsters dumps
dumps
[Music]
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
mangoes my bags are mangoes
[Music]
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost eleven
dollars
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes manga aren't mangoes like
three by seats
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
the prize
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy don't want
[Music]
what an incredible musical element to
kick us off today there is so much to
talk about i'm glad uh that you are
joining me it is just after 4 30 p.m
on the east coast of the united states
just over 1 30 p.m on the west coast and
a lot is happening we have cancellations
we have new things we have all sorts of
different stuff to talk about
uh where to even start it has been 364
days
since the january 6th trump riots and
donald trump has cancelled his press
conference scheduled for tomorrow
probably a good idea
probably a good idea
and we've talked about that on the
podcast today the episode just came out
and it's going to be a big
uh
i don't know if there will be violence
tomorrow donald trump is not doing his
press conference joe biden is
commemorating one year since the event
and then there is also
this is really weird
marjorie taylor greene and matt gates
are kind of doing a response to trump to
a biden's commentary on the one year
anniversary it's not even clear like
what this is going to be
but that's tomorrow afternoon it's going
to be
really really weird
is my expectation
um
we have um
okay we're still working through
some pretty massive oh my god pretty
massive technical difficulties
when it comes to super chats and for now
we're gonna i think i can get them on
the screen this way so for example
chakaseki came in with the first one and
is actually commemorating the one year
since the riots saying david thanks for
your coverage
almost a year ago we watched with you in
horror or hara as some would say as the
rioters launched a violent coup attempt
let's hope for justice yes over 700
um
defendants so far
which is really quite a number and
hold on a second here
we do band for let's go brandon so just
doing a quick band there took care of
that
um
[Music]
okay very very good so number one
super chat's functioning
sir how do you rate blood orange from
the standpoint of citrus i like blood
oranges blood orange is pretty high on
my list last night i had a pomelo which
is kind of weird because
in english the pomelo is different than
the grapefruit
the word for grapefruit in spanish is
pomelo pomelo
so in english it's a different fruit but
in spirit spanish is just a translation
it's all very very complicated but i
continue to take the uh standpoint
that the um satsuma mandarin
is the absolute best citrus i don't i've
never seen citrus i like more than the
satsuma and i picked up i picked up a
bag
at trader joe's the other day big big i
think it was like
could it be 3.99 for a bag of satsuma
incredible deal i mean it's shocking
that these things are being sold this
cheaply
david i'm very involved in the
republican party my whole life and i'm
appalled by what's taking place no one
actually thinks the election was stolen
well i don't know about that i'm going
to play some videos for you in a moment
about that okay
um
wow i was a lot of super chats i was
glued to your stream all that day too
and still somehow trump has a good
chance to win again in 2024 what a crazy
time to be alive absolutely absolutely
okay other announcements so tomorrow
canceled i'll i might stream something
different
uh we'll we'll see what happens i'm
hoping for no violence if there is
violence i will almost certainly stream
because it will be another one of these
seminal moments in american history from
the standpoint of negative of course
number two chess tournament you're all
invited the chess tournament is going to
be tuesday
it'll be on a taco tuesday january 11th
that's a week from yesterday
the tournament will be at 6 pm eastern
time
it will be on chess.com everyone is
welcome everyone is welcome okay i will
be streaming i am ready to announce the
following chess celebrities will be
playing in the tournament
uh international master eric rosen will
be streaming and playing in the chess
tournament
um
now hold on a second
grand master benjamin feingold will be
streaming and playing in the tournament
women's feed master anna kramling
will be streaming and playing in the
tournament and then there's a bunch of
other invites out
um
alex botez said she can't do it she's
tied
up stephen kenneth death anybody second
see how quickly i said that also known
as destiny
is unavailable that day so he won't be
playing
and um
i did invite levy i have not heard back
he's sort of ghosting me right now which
is which is very unlike him but i want
everybody to play okay uh 6 p.m eastern
3 west
tuesday january 11th
it's gonna be fun it's gonna be really
really fun
people of all ages and skill levels are
welcome okay
let's get to
uh what is going on here
matt sends a super chat and says let's
go hamburgers
and mr bloke
smuntz
says david sir do you think a
progressive presidential candidate with
right-wing tendencies like pro-gun could
deprogram the alt-right
theoretically
very very theoretical very theoretical
okay let's get into thanking a few
people then we're going to get into the
meat of today's stream i want to say
thank you to lynn schnug who just signed
up at joinpakman.com
using the coupon code wow 22 and see new
member number one today over on twitch i
want to say thank you to the following
people
beef stews
joe sauce
milo wild
jen here
deeper shades of house
lime green skittles nick lovin skittle
stew
that's eight okay that's just eight that
puts us at nine and continuing today
all patreon pledges during the stream
count double
tiberius just made a pledge at
patreon.com
david pakman show and instead of only
getting us to 10
it actually gets us to
11.
okay if we get to 100 phones open
and it guarantees another stream
tomorrow so that's where we are right
now
oh and thanks to canned caviar
canned caviar re-upping
their twitch prime subscription as well
uh okay other super chats
if i don't play i can assume i'm the
chess champion
whatever yeah i mean sure you know
whatever whatever whatever works for you
sinful all right let's get into stuff uh
so um did chess tomorrow trump canceled
oh you know i
i've seen in the chat sporadically
people asking david why don't you
respond
why don't you respond to people
who say
who do videos about you on youtube
there's all these different youtubers
who do attack videos where they
criticize your position on this that or
the other thing
two reasons basically number one i don't
have time to watch any of those videos
and number two
they're just desperate they're they're
trying to get me into the react game
to give them attention a lot of them
have very small channels when i've
casually looked at some of these um uh
publishers they have very very very
small channels clearly what they're
trying to do is trigger me so i go crazy
and talk about the globalish and you
know all this stuff and attack them and
it gives them attention and it's just i
i just don't care i just don't care so
that's why
there's a whole cottage industry
of uh just doing attack videos
and they benefit from me giving them
attention and i'm just quite frankly not
interested all right
deborah dejong says sir novak djokovic
has just had his aussie visa cancelled i
read that yeah he won't get vaccinated
you gotta you gotta be um
you gotta be vaccinated to go to
australia that's the rule what can you
do what can you do okay let's get right
into the material
uh let's see what did i want to look at
first oh okay so
you know
we were i have to tell you that i'm
gonna pat myself on the back with this
mallet
yeah
we were really one of the first channels
to
in a serious manner
start covering this civil war within the
republican party which originally was
trump versus non-trump
and we've been on this pretty early
we've we've been on it for quite a bit
of time
the next layer in this
is trump on trump hostilities within the
republican party where former trump
people are becoming anti-trump this is a
whole new layer and there is now i'm
going to play a video for you
uh the maggas are revolting this is a
burning maga hat
former arizona republican senate
candidate challenges trump to a million
dollar debate
calls trump quote a little [ __ ]
and then uses a flamethrower to torch
his own maga hat i think this is
fantastic the left is
i you know you guys
do you guys know i call it like it is
and i just tell you what i think like
there's no some you know
people throw around these words grifting
and disingenuous and all you guys know i
just give you my opinion right like
whatever i tell you is what i think do
people in chat can people confirm that
god i think i've been muted this entire
time
people know okay good people know that
good a few people are saying they know
that
um
i think that the left
may be heading towards one of its most
humiliating failures in the next two
election cycles
and 2022 may be
just some of the most pathetic losses by
by the democratic party i think the
democratic party is a disaster
uh i'm on the left
i'm not a democrat i don't care about
parties i think the democratic party is
a is a total disaster
and it desperately needs help and the
type of help it needs is exactly this
type of thing trump versus anti-trump
trump is turning on trump etc etc let's
take a look at this
hey donald trump this is daniel mccarthy
in arizona the world is waking up to
your massive by the way it's like
literally who but okay it's fine drift
please stop with the smoke and mirrors
with these audits stop with your
fundraising stop uh establishment
candidate endorsements stop pushing this
gene therapy the sauce i hear you're
coming to florence arizona for another
one by the way
i've been advised
that
every time there are vaccine dis uh
incorrect vaccine claims made for
youtube standards every time i need to
debunk it
it is not true that the covet vaccines
are gene therapies okay that's me i'm
i'm remaining in compliance
thank you one of your do nothing rah-rah
session rallies well i have an offer for
you i will give one million dollars to
the charity of your choice does this guy
have a million dollars like is he
independently wealthy i don't know who
this guy is
if you take 30 minutes of your stage
time on january 15th
and debate me or answer my questions
even in front of your crowd think about
all the things that you've done that
you've got you've not been held
accountable for you ushered in medical
tyranny
wrong you exploded our national debt
true
you relinquished our sovereignty with
the usmca trade deal false
you passed more gun laws than obama did
with fixed knicks that i don't actually
know
maybe you warned about election fraud
but yet you did nothing to prevent it
even after my team months in advance
warned you after we were stolen from in
the senate primary i gave up on
therapeutics and you push in
experimental gene therapy the vaccine is
not an experimental gene therapy
in that it is not experimental in that
it is the physio vaccine is fully
approved by the fda
it is also not a gene therapy people are
literally dying because of their trust
in you
well no well let's see
yes but oh that's complicated yes people
some people are dying
because they went anti-vaxx
as a result of following trump even
though he's now provac so yes but it's
it's different people than the one this
guy is talking about that's really
complicated you enacted the lockdowns
and you surrounded yourself with swamp
creatures for four years i don't think
trump enacted any lockdowns i believe
those were that was governors right did
trump do anything that was la anything
like a lockdown
the u.s didn't even really lock down
okay the january 6 protesters that came
down to the capitol you set them up
those people are being treated worse
than dogs now and these are your most
loyal supporters well maybe worse than
trump seems to hate dogs
i don't know
trump you failed america true you're the
most deceptive president in american
history true that's true and trust me
there's been a lot of psyops before i've
posted the terms and conditions of my
one million dollar offer to my website
www.demanddaniel.com
i look forward to seeing you on january
15th although i know you won't do it
because you're a little [ __ ] right
[Music]
i don't know i mean listen epic there's
all sorts of this guy doesn't strike me
as the guy who's got a million bucks
hanging around judging partially from
his car
[Music]
this is not a joke by the way
trump won't ever talk to me because he
knows he can't because his family's name
would be tarnished forever
very very ill
um
oh that's a classic car sorry that is
the car of a millionaire fine i mean
listen i don't know that much about cars
i have to tell you
okay um so anyway the maggas are turning
on the magaz a very very strong
flamethrower action as you can see here
extremely extremely aggressive let's
look at a few other super chats sammy
says prisoners treated like dogs what
does he expect a four-star hotel yeah
well you know
suddenly they care about the treatment
of prisoners all of a sudden
let me say a big thank you to windup cat
kiff
and mevilloria for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 15. listen
guys we gotta do a little something to
kick off this year strong we had a very
very tough november and particularly
december so here are all of the elements
on the table for you number one best way
to support what we do sign up at
joinpakman.com above my head you see
that you can use the coupon code obama
that'll give you a huge discount if you
want to pay full price for a year that's
60 bucks i'll send you a free t-shirt
just email info davidpakman.com after
signing up that's option number one
that'll fill this bar option two if
you're watching on twitch or even if
you're not
use your free twitch prime subscription
for our stream it costs you nothing it
just takes a few bucks from jeff bezos
oh by the way did you see those recent
pictures of jeff bezos he looks like
pitbull
it's wild wild what he's doing
um
and then number three
if you make a pledge on patreon
patreon.com david pakman show it'll
count double here i see all of it come
in all of it comes in if we get to 100
we will open phone lines you guys can
call in and we'll we'll lock in another
stream
for uh tomorrow so that's all happening
thanks to agnostic sister for the twitch
prime subscription
okay
um other super chats i don't think i
missed any others let me see here
the super chat system is a little
different today
no i think i got them all very good
oh and thanks to cosmos for the twitch
prime subscription as well very very
much appreciate that oh and aaron
a-r-i-n thank you for the twitch prime
subscription can't thank you enough okay
i do have voicemails but let's continue
all right we already talked about the
gates thing tomorrow with marjorie
taylor green
uh let's go oh oh oh this this is just
beyond belief beyond belief
dot is it donny or dhoni o'sullivan i
always remember
i always forget rather what's the right
pronunciation i want to make sure i get
it right he's a very very good irish
journalist on cnn
is it donny or dhoni
dhoni
people don't know oh it's doni okay
doni o'sullivan
he does these amazing interviews and
there's they're amazing for two reasons
first they're amazing because he asks
really good questions and he gets people
to look really really stupid and he's
scottish oh my god i'm getting
everything wrong so it's not donny and
he's not irish hold on
let me see where he's actually from
no it's it says he's an irish journalist
yeah he's in a i guess he went he has a
masters from queen's university belfast
and originally
from
county carrie that's ireland right guys
that's ireland
dear god okay
so there's two things that he does that
are great the interviews are great and
he gets these
horribly ignorant people to expose
themselves but he also as a comedian
he's doing great physical comedy because
he has a microphone on a boom stand and
that's how he's so i don't i mean i
don't know if it's coveted or what it is
but the visual element of the microphone
on the boom stand i find absolutely
riveting so it's um there's a lot of
really interesting things here these are
this is from a couple weeks ago these
were
trumpists
commenting on
one year out from the
trump riots okay brace yourselves
probably get the kids out of the room
january 6 attack was not the republicans
nor trump it was the democrats were
behind it all
they're the ones that caused it all do
you really believe that
i know it and there is no way
that
a republican
would act that way
and there is no way that trump had
anything to do
with what happened on january 6. so
she's very very out of breath but that's
not substantively relevant that's sort
of the no true scotsman fallacy which is
by definition and i covered this on
today's podcast and i talk about it more
by definition
if a republican would never riot then
you can never actually get her to
consider that those might have been
trump supporting republicans who rioted
it's right i mean it's it's an
indefeasible statement
but what about all the trump supporters
that have been charged and indicted
because it's all democratic
judges and people that were on the take
from the democrats
it's been a year since the attack on the
u.s capitol
and because of disinfectant i know i
like that indicted style and diversion
americans don't they've been indicted
have a shared history a shared
understanding of what happened here on
that day i think the whole
reporting of it is a giant hoax
right we are very peaceful people so it
was a total setup to me it was the fbi
had set it up i don't believe that they
were trump supporters that did that oh
you said the whole thing's a setup you
don't really believe that do you yes
i do
do
because trump won the election
they they
they've proven it over and over again i
really don't over and over again it's
been proven so many times at this point
it's it's almost proof fatigue that
we're experiencing i think trump had
much to do other than people that were
supporters for him
some were involved by the way the let's
go brandon hats like dude
that is giga cringe
they were enticed by
the fbi
and by by you know undercover agents
when i spoke to trump supporters here in
washington on january 6 most were in
denial about the results of the 2020
election do you accept that biden won
the election
absolutely not
biden did not win this election
on january 6 we walked with trump
supporters who marched from the white
house where trump was doing a speech
here to the u.s capitol and as we
arrived here that is when the first
security barrier was breached
[Applause]
at the time some trump supporters told
me they were happy with what happened
here at the capitol are you proud of
what happened here today oh yeah
absolutely
i think we should have gone on in and
yanked
the our senators out by the hair of the
head and drag them out and said
no more i'm absolutely
standing behind 100 percent what
happened here today wow 1 000
it's terrible how this election was
stolen
federal prosecutors have charged more
than 700 people in connection with the
capital rise and repeatedly documented
the writer's support for president trump
but some people in right-wing media have
pushed the dangerous idea that it was
all an fbi plot fbi operatives were
organizing an attack on the capitol
there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that this was some kind of
false flag event staged by the democrats
or the fbi
what would you say to people who say
january 6th was the biggest attack on
american democracy
but amid all the denial and deflection i
met one trump supporter who said it was
important this is like the one mildly
reasonable person he's talk he speaks to
real about what happened on that day
what do you think of the trump
supporters that stormed the capital
oh my
you talk about mis
misfound feelings um
seeing the folks from my side of the
state that were there
and they're not the part of the campaign
that we would like to have do you think
some trump supporters that say it's
antifa it's black lives matter that they
know that that's [ __ ] but they just
don't want to admit it's easier to blame
someone else
everyone is afraid to
you know
take the bullying it's that simple
antonio sullivan joins us now that
question you just asked that last
question it's the one i think about all
the time i i mean you know the people
you are talking to
do they really really deeply believe in
a lot of them
seem to really believe it when they say
it to you or do they just
know
you know
they don't want it to be true and so
they say it's not
yeah i mean i think there are some folks
there who just know this is the talking
point and that's what they should say
and they really do know what happened
but as you see in that piece you know
there are people just like who genuinely
believe the election was stolen yeah
we've been talking about this for a
while which is there's no doubt that
there are people there are people who
are just saying this stuff because it's
what they see as signaling that they're
on the team
they don't really believe it
and then there are people that
absolutely really believe it they
absolutely really believe it and so it's
a mix it's a mix but
really really well done stuff there uh
this woman in particular probably the
most uh the most weaponized i would say
thanks to derrick west derrick just
signed up on my website joinpakman.com
and i really really appreciate that your
new member number 19 today over on
twitch i want to say thank you to ryu
the berninator
and camera tagis for the twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 20 and 21
20 and 21 phones will open at 100.
uh over on
youtube i want to say thanks to ferret
queen who's been a beta member for 16
months who says keep in mind these
people vote
more reason for the rest of us to vote
to outnumber them rather than just
cancel them out apathy is what gave us
trump absolutely
absolutely no question about it
uh very very very well said
okay
let's
continue um so we did this let's go oh
okay so this is i don't even really get
what bill o'reilly is up to at this
point bill o'reilly is the disgraced
former fox news host he appeared on
newsmax
and he he was interviewed
um no no no no it was not it was not
about food by the way how are the
calzones no it was it was not about that
let's check it out i haven't watched
this yet but i flagged it let's see
[Music]
why are so many people turning super
beats
because super beats crystal crowd pushed
into the capital here we go this felt
more like a protest that was getting out
of control than an insurrection it
seemed like these trump supporters were
venting from a very frustrating election
so this is former fox host eric balling
actually i think him and o'reilly both
were fired or resigned from fox
for um
alleged sexual harassment
um okay let's continue
whoops
hold on a second
they sure did there should never be
violence people went too far people were
hurt
a seemingly non-violent protester ashley
babbitt was killed
others seemingly capital police died
from heart attacks
the u.s capital was badly damaged none
of that is okay i'm not excusing any of
that
there were you kind of did when you said
this was just their expression of
frustration that that actually
legitimizes it few who went too far
but here's the rub the left took the
events of january 6 2020 and ran with a
narrative that all conservatives were
the same as these few bad actors who
said that i don't remember that being
said at all
inside the capitol most of them weren't
there most of them would never have done
that that day and that is simply wrong
and the media knew what they were doing
they were painting all on the right with
the same brush as the violent protesters
inside the capitol
don't get me wrong the violent all right
let's go to the o'reilly part here
aired across the country on 200 local
stations but the bosses at the media
company who owned the show got cold feet
and pulled any right-leaning political
content they were airing immediately
probably out of fear of ticking off
their average advertisers i would
suspect but a silver lining to losing
that show here i am at newsmax and
thrilled to be here truth be told so
i'm not here to defend the few fools who
turned a peaceful protest into a violent
scene and where people died but i will
call out the hypocrisy on the left
these lefties in the media are the same
people who called violent mobs of
rioters and looters just a few months
prior specifically blm and antifa these
are the same leftists in the media who
call that
peaceful
billions of dollars in damage what is he
talking about people ultimately died
across the country and america's main
streets went from pleasant to perilous
and the hypocrisy goes deeper with these
lefties these people who are so quick to
call january 6 2020 in insurrection are
the same people who look the other way
during the very violent riots i don't
see that at all i mean again
we
name someone specifically
that my channel has been calling out all
of the violence no matter who is
perpetuating it he's 16 just after the
election of donald j trump for president
in dc
protesters dressed in black some wearing
masks
has moved through downtown streets
setting fires i mean listen i'm against
this obviously knocking down a
free publication stand is different than
breaching the capitol i'm against all of
it but who's saying that since they're
in favor of it smashing storefront
windows
some fighting with police
officers dressed in riot gear responded
with pepper spray and stun grenades
in oakland
officers in portland oregon confronted
thousands of protesters in what police
called a riot some demonstrators smash
store windows i mean it's like even
liberal mainstream cbs is reporting it
as a riot what whoever said that this
stuff was right protesters faced off
with police in other cities too
including oakland denver and minneapolis
in boston
burning cars and smashed windows a small
group of protesters dressed in black
their faces covered armed with hammers
and bricks
forgot about those didn't you so stop
with your one-sided memory stop with
your propaganda media spinning so i
guess this is dishonest and
a what about us sort of perspective
circles
elections are hot button events in 2016
the protests went too far we just showed
you that okay
let's get to the o'reilly violent
if we can
yet they demand that any mistake on the
right and certainly this was
huge mistake
um invading the capital and anybody who
thinks it wasn't
doesn't really understand life doesn't
understand the united states because
when you do something like that
in support of donald trump you hurt
donald trump
and so you're hurting your guy
and you when you
break into the capitol
you're hurting your cause
and
so i say
you know what are you
what are you doing o'reilly sort of
dances around an okay take but he seems
to mostly be against it because it was
bad for trump you think this is going to
turn out well
um
it's almost
inconceivable that a rational person
would go yeah i'm going to break into
the capitol and that's going to help
donald trump in any way it hurt him and
it hurt the conservative cause
yeah and that's kind of what i was
getting into in that monologue there is
they handed these yeah yeah yeah that's
what i meant bill these people handed
the script to the left basically being
able allowing them to paint everyone who
supports trump or even the wider uh even
broader brush everyone who's on the
right and bowling has no idea what's
going on does he an insurrectionist
well i'm gonna be interested to analyze
uh president biden's speech tomorrow
because i know what he's going to do
already he's going to blame trump for
the whole thing
because the left fears the rise of
donald trump
they don't want him to run for president
again he obviously does want to run
and is positioning himself to do that so
they'll use this occasion to demonize
him all the corporate media except fox
news will get on that train
and so we'll hear in 48 hours
still defending fox news it's all
trump's fault trump trump trump and we
won't hear things like
gee
trump told o'reilly
on the tour
that on the fifth of january one day
before he he requested
didn't order because he couldn't
according to constitution ten thousand
guard
to go to washington to protect the
capital we're not going to hear that
from president biden or vice president
harris or from the corrupt corporate
media won't hear any of that
so but i think you'll hear it from the
non-corrupt corporate media which is fox
i guess well no they know now bowling
you're not going to get a fair cut if
you watch the network or cable news
operations
what about this jan six committee uh
bill i mean it they they stacked it with
democrats and they added two republicans
who can't stand trump any uh anyway now
why did they do that this is so
dishonest you guys remember that there
was going to be a fully bipartisan
commission five democrats five
republicans the chair would be a
democrat because democrats control the
house the vice chair would be a
republican
and every subpoena would have to be
signed off on by both the chair and vice
chair that was the plan and then
republicans said no we're not going to
do that unless you also investigate when
steve scalise was shot and all this
other stuff
that's how you ended up with what you
ended up with which is liz cheney and
kinzinger and they're presenting it like
that was the democratic plan all along
it was not very very dishonest cheney
and adam kinzinger both of our
anti-trumpers anyway they wouldn't put
jim jordan on they wouldn't put anyone
who who actually represents jim jordan
was arguably a witness jordan had no
business doing that only trump but
actually represents a conservative voice
on the right yet somehow the the
american public is supposed to to trust
this committee why do we even give them
any airtime or credence
uh i
had cash patel on the no spin news last
night that's my television operation um
you want it you go to billowriley.com so
cash patel was in charge of the pentagon
we should check that out and he
took president trump's request
and he was ready
uh as was the defense secretary to
deploy the chair so you guys sort of get
it let's see what bill o'reilly is up to
i'm sort of curious i'm getting this
message david sir today's show is not
available on the member content page um
as far as i knew it was
we are going to check into that
very very strongly in a moment okay so
here's bill o'reilly's site
let's see he's got his column the sun
shades the truth
i'd like to see some video if there's
any video here
watch the no spin news last night's no
spin use open to all watch i'm really
curious what bill o'reilly's up to let's
see
is there a video here or
hmm this is weird
no spin news video
the media gears up
okay
it feels like there should be a video
right here but there isn't
it's really strange huh
well i don't know what to make of it
maybe if i just disable the ad blocker
let's maybe the ad blocker's the problem
no
all right well
i guess we can't watch it that's too bad
i really wanted to see what he was up to
today's message
read
listen
watch free excerpts let's try that
um
all right let's see what this one is
ah okay here's a video let's see what
he's up to oh they even make it look
sort of like fox news
now the biggest story of the week by far
is donald trump's press conference on
january 6th as i that's sort of not
really true i mean part of the reason
trump canceled it is the networks
weren't going to cover it i said
yesterday this is a trap
all right the media is salivating
they can't wait to get down to
mar-a-lago
to bait him
donald trump into saying something that
either justifies
the january 6th riot
diminishes it
or leads him back
to re-litigate
the 2020 election he's not wrong except
he wouldn't need to be baited it was
pretty damn clear that that was the
point of the entire event
and it became clear that it's sort of
like untenable
um
but he's not wrong in that that's what
had happened he just didn't need to be
baited what the media wants
if they get it and they probably will
they'll blow joe biden off the radar
scope for a month
this is a life line
i mean again he's not wrong that trump
might say something so horrifying if he
did the press conference that it would
take up a couple of news cycles that's
that's not true it's conceivable trump
would say something that insane
to president biden who is faltering big
time
so donald trump and i think he's got to
know it
if he gets into justifying the riot
last january 6th
is gonna not save biden but help him yes
true true immeasurably
and mr biden will hurt his own chances
of securing a presidential nomination
for 2024. true true i went over with
this in great detail i'm not going to do
it again right
all right
but
the most important thing to understand
is
when donald trump says the election was
a fraud
he has a perfect right to say that
so it's not really about the right to
speech it's not about the right to s
it's that's not even what it's about yes
he has a right to say it
under the constitution right but
nobody's questioning his right to say it
constitutionally but he's speaking to
the choir
the people who already will support him
the rest of america is dubious
word of the day about that claim because
no
concrete evidence has been introduced in
court true which is what it would take
now
if mr trump
concentrates
on the facebook guy
mark zuckerberg right
then he's got something
man when your best shot is talking about
zuck
it's not seeming like it's a great
time to do an event you know
if that's what he does on thursday that
could be a big win lead editorial in a
wall street journal today is called
zuckerbox oof
and by the way
is zuckerbucks mildly anti-semitic
can people just i mean like let's take
it seriously i don't nobody likes mark
zuckerberg i get it but is zuckerbucks a
little maybe anti-semitic
i'm trying to figure it out
okay all right let's continue zuckerberg
did tilt this election
in 2020 by donating more than 400
million dollars
to hire people to get out biden votes
that's what it boils down to facebook
also allowed a ton of anti-left fake
news so that's not even totally clear to
me
okay
and not get them out go to the polls get
them out on the mail-ins and anything
could have happened if donald trump goes
there
where the media doesn't want to go
and hammers that
he could come out on top
if he goes back to giuliani and the
others
that is going to hurt him
and if he justifies
the riot
that'll be a catastrophe yeah that's
where we are
we will be live
on thursday
on the first tv on all of our outlets
because
of this press conference it's five
floor at a time
and i want to digest it okay anyway it's
canceled so that's that's basically it
that's it okay a few super chats sounds
like o'reilly successfully convinced
trump to cancel the press conference to
some degree
roger asks how do you digest newsmax fox
oan and the likes of bill o'reilly keep
it up sir thank you
you know i uh i don't have an answer for
you i do the best i can i want to say a
big thank you to michael concannon who
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code wow 22
and is the 22nd new member today
i also want to say thanks to crazy fox
for the twitch prime subscription
bio doom
protein deficient vegan has signed up
carvado is a new twitch subscriber
hippie chick
and kingsman
also lindserman
linzerman
and joystick versus machine that's one
two three four five six seven eight
eight plus twenty two that i can do
uh that is thirty and remember that
there are two coupon codes available for
you today you can sign up on my website
using the coupon code obama
you can also use the coupon code being
used by many here which is wow
22 wow 22. okay let's continue
next
this is an interview that has to be seen
to be believed we looked at some clips
looked at some clips on the podcast but
let's watch the full thing here
welcome back our next guest is someone
close to former president trump an
economist and harvard alumni peter
navarro served as a senior trump
administration official including as
assistant to the president
white house trade and senior economic
adviser peter navarro joining me now is
peter navarro trump that peter navarro
is leaking
their own
january 6 plans the assistant to the
president and director of the office of
trade and manufacturing policy peter
navarro all right okay let's get is our
guest tonight and his new book
in trump time is out now thanks for
being here
all right great to be with you i i guess
i am the trade guy but but tonight i
think uh that i'm the january sixth guy
the in trump time book shows
unequivocally he doesn't even ask the
question yet it's already off the rails
um that
both stephen k bannon and president
trump should be exonerated if any
violence on capitol hill on january 6
and what i show in the in trump time
book
is this plan we had called the green bay
suite clearly between constitutional and
legal lines to basically have only legal
votes counted in the election and we had
you mentioned that
we um we prepared for that so let's take
a look you mentioned this uh this plan
why does peter navarro stand during
interviews and not wear a jacket i don't
know but he always does it it's the jim
jordan move as well here's steve bannon
talking about it on january 6th
so i keep saying the mantra you call the
play now run the play right it's like
the old green bay power sweep it's very
simple very just one thing leads another
very logical and the victories are
firm so go ahead and tell us in your own
words what was the plan and who was in
on it besides you bannon and trump it's
so amazing because he just admits to the
entire thing
sure the back story is while i was in
the administration after the election
beginning on thanksgiving i produced
what would be an exhaustive three volume
report i went over tens of thousands of
pages of documents and proved
that the election was on all likelihood
stolen through fraud and election
irregularities that's untrue back
background country six that's the green
bay sweet plan that's false right so the
premise was completely false continue
question for the start of the interview
yes it is fine but that's the question
for the start of the interview is yeah i
just want to i just want to make sure
here that we're kind of going by rules
of the road the question is yeah i know
and you'll get time to talk you've got
to say that and and what i'm saying is
that i don't have to say anything sir
i'm asking you the question is
what was the plan itself and who was in
on it
exactly and i'm going to tell you that
the plan was simply this we had uh over
a hundred congressmen and senators on
capitol hill ready to implement the
sweep the sweep was simply that we were
gonna challenge
the the results of the election in the
six battleground states they were
michigan pennsylvania uh
georgia wisconsin uh nevada and and
basically these were the places where we
believed that if the votes were sent
back
to those battleground states
and looked at again that there would be
enough concern amongst the legislatures
that
most or all of those states would
decertify the election that would throw
the election to the house of
representatives and i would say to you
here ari that all of this again i was it
was in in the lanes legally it was
prescribed by the constitution there is
a provision to go rather than through
the electoral college to the house of
representatives and all this required
was peace and calm on capitol hill so
his story is the riot hurt their cause
of being able to steal the election and
at 1pm
ted cruz senator ted cruz and gosart a
representative started the green bay
sweep beautifully challenging the
results of arizona here's the most
important thing i can tell you about
this
the the thing that we were trying to
deal with was was a media which refused
to acknowledge any kind of possible
broader regularities
let's get into it i've given you peter
i've given you i've given you is there
any way that this will be an interview
peter
there's some time here and i think you
you've you've explained that and i'm
going to follow up here and i want us to
have a back and forth but that involves
both of us
you just described a way yeah you just
described
this plan
as a way to take an election where the
outcome was established by independent
secretaries of state by the voters of
those states and legal remedies have
been exhausted with the supreme court
never even taking let alone siding with
any of the claims that you just referred
to so legally they went nowhere and then
you're describing a way that the
incumbent hold on hold on you will get
your turn i just let you go for a while
let's go this back and forth sir
then
you will use the incumbent
losing party's power that was the
republican party that was losing power
to overtake and reverse that outcome
do you realize you were describing a
coup
no i i totally reject many of your
premises there first of all the election
was still in doubt and would be until no
second the idea that that secretaries of
state particularly in michigan and
and pennsylvania were like innocent
parties i mean jocelyn benson and kathy
bookfar the secretaries of state in
michigan and pennsylvania they were put
in power by george soros
for the express purpose of shifting the
playing field to the democrats they were
found in both states to have broken the
law the point here is are you was there
fraud that would have changed the
results in those states
and the answer is no i said we were
following the constitution and rules of
the senate to simply get a recount of
what the votes were and we were looking
for these battleground states to
basically
let me press you on this because people
don't always people always hear peter
people don't always hear directly from
the folks involved uh steve bannon as
you know uh is risking going to jail
rather than just provide testimony about
it you by contrast are described in your
book uh some of the same stuff so i
don't know what he's afraid of that
clearly you're not yeah but when you
describe a system where
after all of the legal remedies are
exhausted the people who lost
just make noise and then say that they
won and seize power don't you understand
i mean that's my question for you
because i get to talk to you directly
here don't you understand that if that
actually were the system it would be
dumb
and dangerous
could just get up there and say well we
want to do our own count not the state
law recount not what the supreme court
provides for everyone remembers bush v
gore there are situations where they get
involved but just people in the trump
administration decide well
we disagree don't you understand why
people see
your whatever you want to call it you
don't want to call it a coup your thing
where when you lose you stay in power
they see that as really dangerous
see oh that's bad the presumption is the
remedies were exhausted and my
presumption is the remedies weren't
exhausted at all the remedy
was for vice president pence's the
quarterback and the green bay sweep to
remand those votes back to the six
battleground states for 10 days for a
look to see if there were any election
irregularities or fraud let's get into
that in your book i'm going to read your
book i'm going to read from your book
and then i'm going to go back to you
quickly you said i'm taking that
contention i don't have any contention i
i quoted the facts of the supreme court
it was you should not remember
yeah
they're in the
can live in a world where you say we can
live in a world where you say the
supreme court is in canada you can say
that you have the right to say that but
the supreme court's in dc
and the supreme court
did not take
did not take these cases now let's read
from your book with regard to your
contention about the vice president you
say quote pence refused to take my
repeated phone calls about election
irregularities despite a direct request
from president trump to do so
what was your vision that that you would
get pence to do that which trump
couldn't get him to do
no my only reason to talk to vice
president mike pence was to
explain to him as i documented in my
three volume report that in all
likelihood there were significant
election fraud and irregularities across
the six battleground states i mean these
were ubiquitous uh six dimensions of
fraud i simply wanted to brief mike on
what i had found i had what we call the
receipts and that's all the conversation
why wouldn't he listen to you do you
think why wouldn't he listen to you
well i talked about in the in trump time
book is chief of staff mark short who is
a coke network conservative meaning that
and he's a never trumper basically
walled off vice president pence from the
day march so he's basically saying he
couldn't get access to pence to get
pence to do what he wanted because it
took chief of staff's duties back in
2018 and it was a sad story mike was
always good
that day the thing about mike's betrayal
of president trump which is really
interesting is he never shared the legal
analysis of his general counsel greg
japan right and mark short with pat but
again that really peter that brings us
back
but that brings us back to the same
point
and this may be this may be relevant sir
in future elections which is
don't you think somebody would have
thought of this if the incumbent
administration through the president or
the vice president could just cancel the
election outcome because he goes down to
the senate well then a lot of people
would try to stay in power we have an
entire system designed to thwart and i
want to say this respectfully but it's
the truth people like you to stop people
like you who think that you our entire
system is based on preventing people
like this guy from just stealing
elections point yourself the reviewers
of the voters of the american people of
what they lawfully did that you trump
the supreme court no pun intended people
like you are what the constitution are
designed to stop and it worked and it
did stop you which i guess brings us to
you know this this idea of the goals
that you talk about in the book because
again you're out here you worked for the
president i'm going to let you respond
but in the book you say the goal is not
to get the election overturned today the
goal is to subject the ballots to
careful scrutiny investigation correct
what do you say to the system doing that
not through partisans like you
but in the next time if we hear about
this in the next midterm next election
that's what the states and the courts
already do
well they didn't they didn't do their
duty i mean this was a failure of the
judicial branch you keep saying that the
courts rejected the claims but
everything that went to the courts was
rejected on process not fact there was
no evidentiary hearings including the
supreme court i mean there were three
justices yeah that was bad for yourself
you're describing something that's very
bad for your side which is the cases
were so weak you didn't reach demand
yeah that we were trying to cancel all
right so you guys get it there's just
one well there's just one more minute
we'll watch action and you yourself just
read from my book all we wanted was to
look at what i found look ari the
difference between me and virtually
everybody else in this debate is i did
the homework i i'm the guy who looked at
thousands of pages of documents did the
analysis i went in with an idea just
trying to figure out what happened and
what what happened was a very elaborate
um steal and if you look at the time
magazine molly ball cover story
if you read that they admit they stole
it i mean come on
so well peter again we don't i can't
fact check everything uh in real time
and also do the interview um but but
some of what you said is false
yeah some uh so that that's a pretty
wild interview i have to tell you and um
just just i mean he's admitting to the
whole thing and they act like they're
justified that's the thing admit it and
say it made sense of course we would
steal it i mean we won we won in the end
is their their argument
um i want to say thanks to epic 30 epic
30 just signed up via twitch prime i
really appreciate that i also want to
say thank you to roger yee
for signing up on my website and greg
cooper both used the coupon code wow 22
wow 22. let's look at some super chats
now we know why trump canceled his press
conference he's been talking to o'reilly
yes
chaka seki says navarro's rolled up
sleeves and absurd hand gestures bring
to mind chris farley's motivational
speaker comedy sketch yes very much so
let's see
that is exactly what it brings up brings
to mind
um
this one right
my uh my first guest was the starting
defensive lineman and nose tackle for
his high school football team in
wisconsin hey thanks to jeff waldorf for
the radar live please welcome number 59
chris farley
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway my favorite chris farley moment
is his um
letterman entrance where he seems
completely out of control on cocaine
which he had a problem with i mean i'm
not joking
um
it is one of the most entertaining
pieces of video i've maybe ever seen
look at this
[Applause]
then he picks this guy up and puts him
in a trash can yeah
[Music]
it's crazy it's a level of energy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these would not be downers folks
[Music]
if i recall correctly letterman asks him
if he's okay which you know
[Music]
[Applause]
are you all right
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
my god i mean he was very funny there's
no question about that he was very very
funny
um that is really uh
that is that is really really something
um
do you i think the january 6 committee
or doj will use this info from navarro
who knows who i really don't know
james says those are old videos from
2016 and 2017.
um
which one which ones
what does any what is he talking about
what what videos are old from 2016.
this is older than 2016 and the navarro
interview was
yesterday
does anybody know what we're talking
about
oh we don't know okay
the dumpster no that's this is very old
nobody knows
oh oh the lefty riot videos were from
2016
yeah who who even knows i don't know
guys i want to say thanks to tool moo
and picollo
for the twitch prime subscriptions those
are numbers 34 and 35. okay let's go to
a few voicemails my friends i do have
voicemails2192 davidp
is the
number
uh let's see
mr pacman um
i was very disappointed in yesterday's
show
i mean you had all these salacious
juliet stories
like uh complaining about ocasio-cortez
eating outdoors in florida
and i mean it was just a hit parade of
nonsense
uh just sensationalist type garbage well
we yes and i critiqued it as such the
point of the segment was actually the
double standard of republicans in the
reporting of fox news but i appreciate
the comment
uh nonetheless
um let's see what else we've got here
uh
troy york called in david hackman it's
troy york
again i just watched jimmy dore
and he mocked people like you who keep
uh defending twitter facebook these
social media companies
i don't know what you mean by defend i
mean they are companies that get to have
terms of service i'm not defending
anything in particular
but if jimmy dore is mocking me then
it suggests i'm doing something right my
friends all right and then let's hear
from whitney as well
so um
i got the onion grams
one onion gram what's that
and then i added those all up and then i
divided it by three
and i got an average of five
and i'm like really curious because i
noticed that like five is the enneagram
like specific four on my my enneagram
geez
a lot of enneagram material lately from
whitney
um
here's another one
i was wondering if he's ever been in
england i know you've been to spain
i've been to england and i've been to
spain yes and
it didn't seem like
just from you talking about your
experience there that it was like
you know something you really clicked
with oh no i loved being in spain i
clicked with it a hundred percent and
i've been to spain
and i've been to england
and i'm in california so it's like
basically like mexico
and
or at least where i live
anyways so
what i think
is that
mexicans or south americans are more
like the english
that's not been my experience actually
that's interesting interesting
sociological perspective
i just don't feel like that many
similarities between like mexicans or
south americans
and spain
and
just like kind of an interesting
voicemail i mean it's all wrong but
being off your character i would say
that you're more like english than you
are like spanish
i i'm literally argentinian so i don't
know what that makes me but sounds more
spanish than english
and then
um
yeah just say the other mexicans i've
met it just seemed like you know
just
seems like more like the attitude and
everything
well very interesting sociological
perspective perspectives from uh from
whitney and we really
we really do um we really do appreciate
that in a serious in a serious manner
david pakman i'm sorry i'm calling again
because i'm so triggered and angry by
something i missed as i replayed the
ending of the
interview with david allen or whatever
that guy's name is
david allen roof what on earth is troy
york talking about um i think
you're dead wrong that when you say that
the two million closing cases
um that you can double it without
evidence you claim that those cases are
actually doubling they're probably
triple actually that was an
understatement if anything um
if two million cases are a double of
likely a fourth of the real actual cases
which anyone who dies they claim is
being coded
okay so that is not true that is not
true i think it's important to mention
man that really just doesn't it's like a
it's like the mind has turned to
mayonnaise i want to say thanks to aj
four for signing up via twitch prime
you're number 36 today and thanks to
bizarro navarro for signing up you are
number 37 today all right everybody
that's everything i had
i may be back tomorrow we'll see what
happens january 6th anniversary a lot of
different things going on we'll see what
happens i may see everybody tomorrow
we've got the chess tournament on
tuesday and a lot of things happening
between now and then thanks for joining
me see you
very very soon